we are here season 24. when you hear
that 24 seasons could you ever imagine
no
um I can't imagine I have been doing our
show Little People Big World since about
2004 when we had to do a couple of
pilots and then it came into a series
around 2006. I thought oh who's gonna
watch it this will be done in two
seasons or whatever
hope the bumpers are up
oh that wasn't right
[Music]
unbelievable and lo and behold you know
here we are and when I first met Chris
you know he was very very hesitant
and I said I don't blame you but
um I'm glad he's you know willing to to
partake in this for the last six years
yeah when I started you know I agreed to
the cameras as a novelty yeah something
different but I didn't want to do
interviews didn't want to tell anybody
you know a bunch of strangers while I
was feeling yeah I still have trouble
with that when I first met Amy it was
definitely assumed at that time that one
of the kids or more would be living on
the farm and and taking it over why they
could sad and unfortunate that it hasn't
worked out that way well the other thing
is too I mean having started all the way
back then into where we're at right now
I've seen the progression at least
through our show you guys I mean you
really showed the the highs the lows the
UPS the Downs you know you put the real
in reality TV like they still think they
did nothing wrong Zach and Tori have
really isolated themselves you know from
me and Cha-Cha will we see by the end of
the season Matt and Zack and Tori work
out their issues
Chris you looked off you locked off and
did the distance
I think you know this is a situation
that's not Hollywood and it's definitely
not driven by episodes I think people
will just have to watch and see
but in the long run my hope is that
whatever works for them
they'll come to something
so that
you know the kids and them can at least
have some kind of relationship they'll
never be the same they'll never be what
it could have been ever ever but to work
on what can it be what what does that
look like you know moving forward in the
future so people just have to
watch for you as you know a mom as a
grandma as a wife and for you to like
when you watch these episodes play out
is it difficult for you to relive
certain things well I think for Chris
and I we probably have a little
difference of it because I typically do
not watch my own episodes because of the
very fact that I
did it I've lived it six months ago and
then over the years I've said oh boy man
they really had to capture that when
we're fall should have changed that
should have said that different and so I
I don't want to constantly feel like I'm
looking back but he loves watching them
and so I'll do it because he likes to
but I'll be in the background doing
something else or something well I enjoy
it because it it's uh it's fun to relive
those moments again and I really enjoy
because I know all the characters so
well
um the people I was gonna say in the
characters
well they are characters and I don't
mean that in a in a TV sense I just mean
that I mean I call anybody that has an
unusual personality or character meeting
Chris has definitely changed my life I
thought it was clear don't assume that
we had a little bumps I think like any
married couple would I sometimes am a
little sensitive all it takes is one
little thing and then poof
so with all that being said you think
you got another 24 seasons in you oh I
gotta I gotta get to retirement I mean
Chris and I kind of talked about it I
mean we we we we think we do I'm
grateful that all my kids are doing well
I like the generational that's happening
within our family so we'll see but sure
you want more babe can we do more show
them how fun it is to be 60. well I love
that we're getting to see your love
story continue to play out and I mean
you two really I feel like are just such
a match made from heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
I never would have guessed that when we
met each other but it's it's turned out
pretty good this friendship that you two
have found in this chapter of your lives
together do you hope that maybe Matt and
Karen follow suit I think they're
definitely going to get married it's you
know we don't know exactly when they're
going to keep it uh kind of low-key you
know
Matt's already shared that with me but
it'll be kind of low-key and small yes
buddies everything I I love that you
guys show other families that that
little thing bothers me okay you
understand this is my ax you understand
there's a reason why he's my ex
and and sometimes when he does that and
I keep trying to remind her we all grow
and change and with age and most of us
become better people but one of the
things I did tell myself about Chris has
never been married and doesn't have kids
I'm the one if you want to consider it
baggage obviously I don't consider my
kids a grandkid baggage but it is an
element that he's not used to and but I
also look at whatever Matt and I need to
do or deal with or however we get along
for the sake of each other or the kids I
didn't want it
air if I had any negativity or bad
feelings or whatever it may be I'd
rather keep them more to myself than
you know have him look at my whole
family my growing up and even my ex in
such a bad negative way because maybe I
was too afraid he'd be like okay so why
why am I dating no but you do show other
people out there too who might be
struggling with trying to blend their
families and you you the show itself
airing your highs and lows shows other
people that they can get through it they
can get to the other side they're very
respectful and and welcoming and you
know and we try to be the same I mean it
is getting easier and one thing I've got
to say about the whole Roloff Clan
is that no matter what turmoil is going
on between Father and Son or in between
the siblings they put that aside for the
grandkids whether it's a birthday or any
other celebration all are welcome no one
is excluded and
I'm impressed with how well that they
handle that because in the end we still
got to stay connected and when it really
counts I mean you should at least be
able to count on some of the family to
rise to the occasion and be there for
each other so what will the holidays
look like for the family
well I mean the the one thing I I really
tried hard at because I hear so many
stories at the time before I was
divorced how all the kids struggle with
where do we go you know so I I told my
kids when they got married and started
having kids I don't need it on
Thanksgiving Day or Christmas day but
can I have it within the few days of
that holiday I like to be around family
Chris loves to be around family as well
and so I usually have something at my
house whoever wants to come great
or I'll have another day with one of the
kids but because you know they've got
their in-laws and they have their dad I
just want to make it easy for them
[Music]